the endometrium is the mucosa that lines
the inner walls of the uterus an
endometrial biopsy is the removal of
a sample of tissue from the endometrium
for evaluation
a biopsy may be done to
detect cancer or precancerous cells
to determine the cause of
irregular bleeding or to investigate
fertility problems this procedure
can also diagnose infections and
check the effectiveness of certain
medications an endometrial biopsy
can be done in the
doctor's office and can take 10 to 15 minutes
without the use of a sedative
the doctor will first feel it
to determine the  position of the uterus
and then insert the speculum into the
vagina to open and hold it
open so that the cervix is
y visible the doctor may use a
other instrument called a tenta
le to hold the cervi
and hold it steady during the proce
ure then move into a tube
flexible long and thin  or called
paper through the vagina and cervix and
inside the uterus the paper cannula is
equipped with a
plunger-like device that creates suction when
pulled out
the doctor will rotate the paper cannula and
move it up and down  down into
the uterus while suctioning out an
appropriate sample of endometrial tissue then
remove the paper cannula and place
its contents in a container the doctor will
complete the procedure by removing
the tentacle and speculum
after the biopsy some patients
will be able to sit up immediately and feel
cramps  mild other patients who
may feel dizzy will be asked
to rest for 10-15 minutes
before leaving
an anti-
inflammatory medication such as ibuprofen or
naproxen is usually prescribed to minimize any
discomfort or menstrual-like cramps
the doctor will send the sample to a
laboratory  to analyze it the
results can be provided  r over the
phone or during a
follow-up appointment with the doctor